I don't like the conversations of
strengths and weaknesses because
strengths often have
liability I'm really confident okay in
the wrong context you're arrogant but
weaknesses also have Silver Linings yes
it's important for us to understand our
characteristics that we exhibit of which
some of them in certain contexts are
huge strength and some of the the exact
same characteristics in the wrong
context are huge weaknesses right so
it's very it's we have to be very
careful when we label people or
Generations as being strong or weak
because the answer is it depends we have
to take the time to Foster and take care
of people around us to nurture our
relationships because when we're going
to be doing something difficult when
we're going to be swimming Upstream when
we're going to be innovating and and and
and and doing something different there
are days we're going to doubt ourselves
there are days we're going to get
knocked in our ass there are days that
storms are going to rise and we have to
have people who say I got your back you
need to do this